[Music]
we are
very given to believing that a lot of
what we become a lot of who we are is
determined by our upbringing and our
environment that's critical to our
success in life
and to shaping the people we become
but of course a lot of recent research
has also pointed to the fact that
our genetic inheritance an awful lot of
our genetic makeup is going to determine
rather long-term traits and
characteristics of who we are what we
can be what we can do
so is
our dna and is our genetic inheritance
more responsible and more influential
for who we become than say our parental
upbringing or our circumstances
we're all obviously a mixture of biology
and culture and one of the most
difficult things is to find out which
bit is responsible for which and to help
me disentangle that this evening we have
on
on my right your left robert plummen who
is an eminent geneticist and
psychologist and he's also the author of
the recent book blueprint how our dna
makes us who we are
next to him we have angela ceni
and angela is an award-winning science
journalist and the author of superior
the return of race science
on my other side i've got simon baron
cohen who is the director of cambridge
university's
center for autism research and he's also
the author of the essential difference
and then finally but by no means least
we have gunesh taylor who's a geneticist
at the francis crick institute in london
and who focuses on the genetic
determination of sex characteristics
so would you please welcome our panel
for this event
so as i mentioned in my brief
introduction we know that there's a
mixture of nature and nurture and we
know that we have genetic inheritance
and we also have influences on us from
the environment so i'm going to ask each
of our speakers to take three minutes to
set out their stall
on
whether there's a greater influence
perhaps from
what our genes provide us with as our
starting kit or whether it's really to
do with our environmental shaping of
what we're given in that
initial inheritance so robert would you
start us off please thank you thank you
for doing this
why do you think you are the person you
are say your personality are you shy
mental health and illness are you
depressed often or cognitive abilities
how well did you do at school when we
think about what made us who we are it's
easy to
think about those things you can see and
feel like your parents and upbringing
the school you went to your friends
what i'm going to talk about is
inherited dna differences which you
can't feel in the same way
um and so for 45 years i've been
studying the extent to which genetic and
environmental differences are
responsible for making us who we are
this research a huge area of research
has been going on for a century
looks at it describes what is in a
particular population with a particular
mix of genetic and environmental
influences it's not talking about what
could be in another population or
another time it describes what is
this book blueprint is the culmination
of my 45 years of research and i
conclude that inherited dna differences
are the major systematic force making us
who we are as individuals
that research points to the importance
of the environment
but it also shows the environment works
very differently from the way we thought
it worked it's not due to the systematic
influences that we call nurture
parenting so there's a chapter that's
called parents matter but they don't
make a difference
and that's what it's about that you know
parents obviously do matter but
differences in parenting don't make much
of a differences in children's outcome
we don't have as much control over the
development of our children because
genetics accounts for about half of the
differences between children on just
about any trait that you can imagine
so that's sort of the first part of the
book that dna matters the environment it
doesn't work in the systematic way that
we assumed it worked and so what i mean
is that if you were cloned and your
clone was reared in a different woman
grew up in a different family went to
different school your clone when it grew
up would be
very similar to you you'd notice how
similar you are physically you'd be very
similar because that clone is like an
identical twin
they'd be as similar as identical twins
reared together because rearing together
doesn't make you similar what runs in
families is dna so if you've seen this
film three identical strangers about
three identical twins they're triplets
they're clones of one another reared in
very different environments their
similarities are amazing it's a dramatic
illustration of what we have a mountain
of evidence for showing the importance
of nature and not nurture the
environment's important but it doesn't
work the way we thought it worked it's
unsystematic it's called non-shared it
makes kids in a family different from
one another so that was the first 30
years of my career and then along came
the dna revolution and we probably won't
talk about that much today but it's
going to change everything because we
can now read our dna blueprint and
predict problems and promise from birth
thank you robert
are we just our genes let's let's have
the view from angelo on this well i'm a
science journalist so
you know i'm not there doing research
and coming up with theories of my own
and my job as well as to kind of
understand the science and then convey
it to the public it's also to unpick
why scientists do what they do why they
say what they say the agendas
motivations the funding behind the
research that gets done and try to put
research in context and in some ways
give the long view and we have to
understand that this debate that we're
having now is a debate that has rumbled
on for more than a hundred years
um and it started when we talk about
nature versus nurture that phrase
originated with sir francis galton
the man who
invented eugenics he was a cousin of
charles darwin and for him this really
went to the heart of the problem how can
we distill
what portion of who we are is down to
genetics and nature
and what portion of who we are is down
to external circumstances like
environment and culture and society and
that
pitting these two things against each
other and trying to weigh up which one
has more weight than the other is an
exercise that scientists have been
doing for like i said decades many many
decades
have they got any further along
yes in some ways because we do have
more understanding of how genes work now
and the kind of work that robert does
looking at
genome-wide association studies and
looking at links when we see twins you
know how much of that is down to nature
and how much is done to nurture but i
think what is becoming
clear from having spoken to lots of
scientists who work in this field is
that these things are not two separate
things they work in tandem with each
other so when you have
um
an environmental
kind of exposure that affects your body
in quite a visceral way it even affects
the development of your brain so we know
for instance neuroscientists know that
um taxi drivers in london and we've had
this research for a long time the areas
of their brain associated with memory i
think are larger because they're
exercising that area of their brain and
that when they stop being taxi drivers
that
change starts to be reversed and so the
this idea that you know there is some
innate
portion of you that is fixed and never
changes on the day that you're born and
then there's also another part of you
that is just what culture and society
and environment and nutrition have given
you and these two things are somehow
separate i think is not really the way
to think about these things it's not
nature versus nurture it's nature and
nurture together and
we don't have the full answers yet i
would say thank you i have to say that
whenever taxi drivers boast to me about
their hippocampus getting so big because
they did london knowledge i have to tell
them that means some other bit of your
brain was reduced
probably the political sensitivity part
[Laughter]
so um simon nature nurture are we making
progress is it the right question
um well i'm glad to hear angela saying
that it's not about nature versus
nurture
because that was a kind of old debate
and i think
um this festival is all about how the
light gets in and if we're still
debating nature versus nurture it means
the light hasn't really got in
we we now all recognize that these
interact
i i was pleased to hear robert making
the case for genetics because
we do now have lots of ways of measuring
what's called heritability
whether it's through twin studies like
the ones that robert does or comparing
children with their parents or looking
at the dna itself there's a lot of ways
of measuring heritability
and there isn't really any question that
herod that traits human traits are
heritable
we can look at physical ones like height
and weight and they are
strongly heritable at least fifty
percent
but that means that there's a genetic
predisposition
interacting with environmental factors
when it comes to behavior
um you know robert said parents matter
well i would make the case a bit more
strongly that i really do think
um
early influences
from parents
from the environment on how children
um
are nurtured
are hugely important
particularly for emotional well-being
but we shouldn't be losing sight of the
genetic predisposition that is also a
driver for behavior i work in the field
of autism
so autistic kids um as you all know
struggle to socialize struggle to
communicate
and have
rather narrow sometimes called obsessive
interests autism seems to be strongly
genetic you can look at the heritability
of that
and it's some estimates are as high as
60 or 80 percent so
genetics is playing a big role and when
the molecular biologists
look for the genes for autism
we've now found
about a hundred genes which contain rare
mutations that are
associated with those sorts of behaviors
they don't account for the majority of
autistic people because these rare
mutations are only found in about five
percent of autistic people
but we know autism runs in families
autism is strongly genetic
so the genetic contribution is probably
probably also coming from common genetic
variants
so these are variants that we all carry
in different
uh different forms
common variants
that you find in any population and it's
probably the combination of those common
variants
that is contributing to the genetics of
something like autism
but to find those common genetic
variants nowadays we've realized you
need really big studies
um each of those common genetic variants
may only be having a tiny effect
so to detect them you need population
studies of the scale of ten thousand
twenty thousand even a hundred thousand
people
in one group compared to another group
and we are in cambridge just launching a
new study on the genetics of autism
where we're collecting dna from 10 000
autistic people
so genetics and environment
simon thank you gunesh where are you
standing on nature and or nurture
yeah thanks as was mentioned in the
introduction i'm i'm a scientist i'm a
molecular biologist and i study genes so
i can't honestly say that genes don't
matter because i'm afraid they do matter
um but what i understand of the question
you know nature versus nurture i think
is is more what do we what do i do as a
human being what do i do as a user with
information about this sort of
information i think that's actually what
the question is and not to completely
derail the debate
but um
so you know um
i could i could now rattle off
information about you know we know
increasingly certain genes that are
incredibly important for uh determining
maternal behavior at least in mice for
example if you carry a mutation in this
particular gene and you're a mouse you
won't look after your pups
you know those kinds of studies
obviously do exist they they are
published they i trust them as a
scientist i look at them with the
critical eye but but that's sort of a
scientist's endeavor right
what then happens is these studies get
published and
everybody else including myself as a
human being who doesn't actually specify
and who doesn't specialize in this stuff
reads it and goes what does that mean
for me as a potential mother in the
future what does that mean what does it
mean right
um
and i think i think that's what the
debate's about basically what what you
know i it's undeniable that genes and
your genome
is the basis of who you are as a person
it's undeniable because you start off as
a single cell that is just instructed
with that information that is the basic
starting point of your life it is what
determines how you grow what shape you
are and all the rest of those things
however
we all do many things in our lives that
that aren't necessarily written in our
genes right
i don't know about you guys i don't feel
particularly comfortable in this blazer
right now but i'm wearing it because
it's socially determined that i should
be doing something like that right
you know
sometimes you get angry at people and
you think i wanna you know
but we have society that tells us things
like don't hit people that you don't
like because it's not okay
so we all learn to do things that we we
would you know arguably be going against
our predetermined genetic nature right
so the real question actually i think
that we're faced with at the moment is
in this era of increasing knowledge and
people like myself and others on this
panel spewing out more and more facts as
it were data about who we are and what
our genes say we are is actually what do
you want to do with that information
about yourself what kind of person do
you want to choose to be in light of
this information
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas